welcome back to Hannity as we are in
beautiful Palm Beach Florida where I sat
down with former president Donald J
Trump earlier take a look
in a mass the most about about you of
late is Ron DeSantis
this is the question
what happened
I thought they were friends
what happened not friends I didn't know
him well but he was on impeachment hoax
number one and impeachment hoax number
two which I won Defender you he was one
of 150 people that would go on
television and defend me and he was no
Jim Jordan he was no I mean I had a lot
of people that really defended me Greg
but he was good and he defended me
so all of a sudden he's running for
governor and people didn't view him as
Governor because you know he was a
congressman defending and they reviewed
Ms governor and he announced he was
running for governor and he wanted to
get my support now I didn't know the
person that was running named Adam
Putnam he was the secretary of
agriculture which is actually the second
highest position in Florida it's a big
deal agriculture is very big and it goes
back a hundred years and all of that but
agriculture is very big very high
official
and popular Adam Putnam and what
happened but I didn't know him and I
knew Ron a little bit I didn't know him
very well but I knew him a little bit I
know him as somebody that
defended me so what happened with Iran
is the following he came to see me he
was getting killed he was being crushed
Adam Putnam it was over I have many
people that I know that worked for Adam
Putnam they said it was like a nuke I
hate to use this expression it was like
a nuclear weapon went off when you
endorsed because they considered the
race to be over they had the race he had
millions and millions of dollars and he
was way up in the polls he was beating
Ron by 30 points or so it was over
Ron came to see me tears in his eyes
he said I need you to do me a big favor
first he asked for the meeting then he
asked me for the favor
I said what's the favor
would you endorse me
I fought for you and but again he a lot
of people fought for me you fought for
me only rightfully but you fought for me
if you thought I was right a lot more
than he did
but he said I need your endorsement
I said Ron you're so far behind I can't
imagine that if you've got George
Washington's endorsement
combined with the great late great
Abraham Lincoln if you had their
endorsements I don't think you could win
run but
tell me about it go ahead he said I'm
telling you I think I could win if I
could get your endorsement and he was
you'll have to check the records but
many many points it was over and the
nomination just very closely the
nomination was just okay
I gave I said let's give it a shot okay
you know you defended me Adam Putnam
didn't one way or the other I think he's
probably a nice guy you know I never met
him until later a year later I met him
he said when you did that it was like a
rocket went up he said my race was over
they were already buying furniture for
the for the Governor's Mansion they were
going to win so I said let's give it a
shot Ron okay and he was desperate
I said okay I gave him a nice
endorsement I said you write out what
you'd like and let me see it he wrote it
out I thought it was terrible I changed
it made it great I gave him a great
investment
from the moment I pressed that button
he blew the guy away the race was over
they never even got to spend their money
then I had him get him I had to get him
against the star of the Democrat Party
was going to be Stacey Abrams and the
now we call him a crackhead because
that's what he was a crackhead his name
kill him kill him and there was no way
Ron was going to beat Gillum so he got
the nomination but there was no way
because this guy was going to be the
future of the Democrat Party
and I said Ron you can beat this guy
let's go
I got him the nomination by the way
couldn't have never gotten a nomination
he would be working in either a pizza
parlor place or a law office right now
okay and he wouldn't be very hassle it's
about loyalty it is to me okay let me
just so what happens is
I did stops I had thousands of people
going to rallies you know my rallies in
history there's never been rallies like
this I don't just mean in this country I
mean in any country
you just take a look at Waco Texas from
just last night you just take a look it
was
unbelievable and and by the way that's
sort of like we really beating Taylor
Swift by the way yeah I did the j6 is
beating Taylor Swift it's Donald Trump
and the j6 Cruisers the Pledge of
Allegiance on iTunes and on Amazon and
on Billboard which is the big deal
number one Donald Trump so now I feel
like Elvis because now we've done The
Apprentice that was a great success we
did now I've done now I've done a
recording or whatever you call it but no
it was number one and you know what that
is that's a tribute to the fact that
people feel the j6 people have been very
unfairly traded just to finish up with
the sentence so I said let me do a
couple of rallies I did a couple of
rallies two or three massive rallies
massive I said you're going to win Ron I
don't think so he's a star I said you're
going to win I'm telling you
and he ends up winning
and then a couple of years later they
say to run to santis will you run
against the president and he said
I have no comment I have no comment
and I looked at the people I was with I
said that's not supposed to happen here
I got him the nomination and I don't
mean I got them like because you know
what I help a lot of people
a couple I absolutely made I helped the
governor of Georgia and I would say he
hasn't been exactly great
as far as a relationship I helped a lot
of people get elected I mean I could
name five Senators but I could name 25
Senators that I helped but some I got in
Ron I got in he was losing there was no
way it was over he was dead he was going
to drop out he was gone and then when
they asked him is he going to run he
said I have no comment
and a lot of people political people
said sir never bring that subject up the
voter doesn't care about that subject
but I do and I think people do care
about loyalty when you help somebody
really help them I mean get them and
then he announces that essentially he's
going to run against you guess what he
announced because when he said that that
means to me that you're going to run
right and he's going to run but he's
getting crushed now in the polls because
he did a little things like voting
against Social Security
voting against Medicare his numbers
aren't very good on covet hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else